[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday october the
28th
my name is freddie gray i'm the
spectator's deputy editor and i will be
your host today
we've got a great show on for you we'll
start with the chancellor rishi sunak
who has announced his budget this week
he promised to
cut taxes by the end of this parliament
but also promised a lot more government
spending
we'll be asking if rishi's sums add up
next covid covid cases have been on the
rise alarmingly for quite a few weeks
and yet recent data suggests they may be
tailing off
i'll ask tim spector if there's good
news on the horizon
after that we'll be discussing terrorism
and psychosis
rod little and peter hitchens will have
a mental debate
then cop 26 the big climate change
summit which starts this weekend in
glasgow will be asking if these major
events ever actually achieve anything
or is it all hot air
and finally facebook
is the widespread call for online safety
really a bid to stifle free speech
i'll be talking to the new york times's
media columnist ben smith
and the equally notorious journalist
glenn greenwald who's based in brazil
before we get going though please
consider subscribing to the spectators
youtube channel you can do that by
hitting the red button at the bottom of
the screen
and then tapping the bell at the top to
make sure you never miss an episode
and while you're at it why not subscribe
to the spectator magazine itself you can
get 12 weeks of the magazine and a free
20 pound amazon voucher
for just 12 pounds
to take up the deal go to spectator dot
co dot uk forward slash tv offer
first up the budget rishi sunak has
promised a lot more government spending
including the reinstatement of the
foreign aid budget next year
he's also introduced
tax cuts on universal credit
i'm joined now by katie balls and kate
andrews to discuss
katie i saw a lot of people
outside the two chairman pub last night
from the treasury department and they
were looking jubilant they clearly
thought it was a case of job well done
are they right to be celebrating
yeah it's a little bit early i think um
to have your budget celebration if you
think about
previous budgets ultimately i don't
think the treasury can breathe a sigh of
relief until you get past the sunday
newspapers um people still going over
those figures we're hearing analysis
from the ifs and others about you know
how much rishi sunak is really spending
and what this means uh for the country
in the coming years so it did feel
slightly premature um to be honest and i
think particularly when you think about
it uh the chancellor has just announced
a range of measures which means we are
heading to the highest tax burden since
the 1950s and that's not normally
something on paper that would lead to
mass celebrations at least in the tory
party
kate there's a lot of concern about
inflation uh at the moment and
there's some thought that the chancellor
is trying to put the frighteners on the
economy to a certain extent to to calm
down
uh the inflationary trends do you think
he succeeded in doing that
i think he's being more honest about the
fact that it's very difficult for him to
really claim to have that power i mean
he said on multiple occasions now over
the weekend on the today program that he
doesn't have a magic wand to address
what's really contributing to inflation
right now which is a global gas shortage
uh supply chain uh crunches and labor
shortages
which are putting real inflationary
pressure
on the uk economy and on the global
economy
the best thing he can do is continue to
hedge against inflation and as the
spectator reported back in march that
march budget and the tax rises that we
saw there were really to tackle that
problem to make sure that he had say 20
25 billion pounds at his disposal if
inflation interest rates were to go up
by even one percent which he he thought
he he might actually need so i think you
know in his best case scenario he'll
continue to try to keep that money aside
if he has to pay more to service the
uk's debt um but in that best case
scenario he doesn't have to you know
inflation is transitory as the central
banks continue to promise us it is
although that definition of transitory
really does seem to be elongating um and
he'll be able to spend it on something
else come next year
maybe getting closer to an election that
might look like a tax cut but in in the
worst case scenario he's he's gonna have
to spend that money and even possibly
find more i thought it was interesting
that the officer budget responsibility
um said that they thought inflation
would peak around 4.4 percent next year
i wouldn't say the chancellor played
that down in the budget but he said it
would be around four percent but what he
didn't include that the obr says is once
they brought their forecast to an end
because they have to do that obviously
at some point so the chancellor can
compare prepare for the budget
actually the energy crisis now makes
them think that the risk is to the
upside and it could be around five
percent i mean this is a huge difference
from where we've been the past decade
and indeed for decades when it comes to
inflation and i'm i'm not convinced yet
that the chancellor anybody else has
really explained to the public how much
that's going to bite
is the chances real problem that he's
trying to be all things to all people he
wants to appeal
uh to fiscally conservative tories
and at the same time he's keeping the
government spending gun firing as
regularly and as hard as he can
i think that's what he's trying to do i
think that you saw that yesterday where
you have richie soon announcing
lots of spending measures and as we
touched on the effects of those are
going to be wide reaching in terms of
the tax burden but then throwing in at
the chambers like you know by the end of
the parliament he wants to be lowering
taxes not raising them and then later on
uh in a private audience of tory mps
laying on even thicker
ultimately talking about how going
forward um his main goal is going to be
lowering taxes and that's how he's going
to look at every marginal pound
do we believe him
i think there's quite a lot of
skepticism amongst uh tory mps because
ultimately there is a bit of a running
joke with ministers that every time
rishi scenic starts to talk about how he
is a low tax tory it usually means he's
about to do the opposite and he's trying
to say oh i am doing this but i don't
mean to i think in the chancellor's
defense when we're looking at this
budget to me the budget and the spending
review almost boris johnson um events
and you could see rishi senior flicking
to that he kept talking about the prime
minister's uh you know ambitions when he
was speaking and i think that reflects
the fact that we're rishi sooner prime
minister i don't think he would be doing
the level of spending that we saw um
this week i think that is pressure
coming from number 10. i think the
question is is rishi sunik really going
to be able to turn the tide and move to
lower taxes by the end of this
parliament if you do have that pressure
coming from number 10. and i i think of
all the strain that we're hearing about
it is not clear that he will be able to
do that significantly
kate we we in the um osborne cameron
cameron osborne era i should say we got
used to this idea that um george osborne
the chancellor was really the driving
force of the government uh and that
seems to be the impression in the
johnson sunac era
is it a similar dynamic
oh i'm not convinced it's all that
similar so i think when it comes to
personal relationships there's every
indication that boris johnson and rishi
sunac are very friendly they get on and
there was a lot of briefing leading up
to this budget that the chancellor was
more left less to his own devices but
there's a huge caveat there that i don't
think was existing in the cameron
osborne era for quite obvious reasons i
mean that was an era that the government
was almost proud to define as austerity
so when osborne was trying to get the
books in order he had all the support
from david cameron and you know they
they were far from perfect but that was
the goal and and you did see uh the
deficit coming down what we have now is
rishi sunax told he can be left to his
own devices with a huge caveat that he
has to deliver on the prime minister's
spending plans he has to deliver on the
manifesto he has to deliver on the
promises and boris johnson has made some
wild spending promises we're investing
in just about everything infrastructure
the nhs education you name it boris
johnson wants money money funneling into
it and he wants more day-to-day spending
as well as more capital spent so rishi
sunak is walking this very fine line
where he has to make his neighbor and
number 10 happy
he has to show that this is not an
austerity government and he certainly
did yesterday i mean this is not a
government that is trimming anything
back
but at the same time he wants to signal
to his party and also to the markets
that he is going to be fiscally
responsible which is why you're not
seeing him use all of the borrowing room
in the windfall room that he might have
otherwise done if he just really wanted
to spend and i think his language at the
end of the speech did matter i mean it
was very blunt it was saying you know if
you think it's controversial now to say
government isn't the answer to
everything then it's important that i
say it i'm paraphrasing him he said it
better than i did i think his point
there was to every department you have
to stop asking me for emergency money
because we may have a lot of
consequences we have to tackle from kova
but we are no longer in an emergency and
getting the public finances somewhat in
order is a top priority for sunac but as
katie says i think on the tax stuff that
is going to be the harder argument to
make i mean it is all good and well to
say look i really don't want to be
raising these taxes which he's done many
times to tell tory mp's behind closed
doors i'm going to do everything i can
to get taxes down but if you're the
chancellor that rose tax and didn't get
taxed down i mean that is the record
you're going to be judged on so i think
the pressure is actually really hyped up
and is on rishi sunac to deliver this
now
katie do you think that tensions are
growing between the chancellor and the
prime minister
i think when you look at their
relationship i think it has become more
strained than it was when rishi senate
was first appointed chancellor i think
that's some of that i think is uh
inevitably what's going to happen when
you have the treasury and dining street
the treasury is always going to be the
uh the body which is effectively saying
oh think about this where's the money
coming from but i also think there is
an ideological difference between richie
sunak and boris johnson i think boris
johnson is far more relaxed about almost
not having an ideology on on the economy
and and throwing money at things and i
think the chancellor's much more nervous
i think we could really see it at a tory
conference uh where rishi sunik has been
worrying for some time about inflation
when he spoke to the spectator last
christmas he spoke about his inflation
fears um and lots of people said well
this is misfounded um at conference just
as you have lots of warnings that this
really could be about to happen and get
quite a bit worse you have boris johnson
saying that inflation fears are
misfounded um it feels as though they're
in two very different places and i also
think that since you've seen a change of
personnel in number 10 so the departure
of the vote league group people like
dominic cummings who often uh
complimented rishi soon i can still do
to this day in his um very long blogs um
i think the new team uh you know
a bit more suspicious of that and
therefore there's
been a bit of a break in terms of um the
relationship between the two on a
personal level in terms of their teams
as well so i think that all that comes
together to mean that this is not a
david cameron george osborne
relationship
katie kate thank you very much
thanks fred
next
coved covered cases have been rising
alarmingly for quite a few weeks now but
the latest data from the government
anyway suggests that they might be
finally falling off
i'm joined by tim spector who is
principal investigator as you all know
of the zoe app
tim
are we seeing a decline in cases or do
you see something different from your
information
yeah for once we have a a clear
difference between the methods of
collecting data so that the
government confirmed cases which is just
based on uh positive reported tests to
the government uh is showing uh about
half the rate of the zoey and a decline
over the last three days
whereas the latest zoya today is showing
around 93 000 new cases
and a slight increase day on day
although uh we are now showing a a
decrease in the in the increase if you
like so it only increased a few thousand
the last few days
so there's a quite a big gap in the um
in the numbers and there's also
uh it's unclear really whether we are
heading for a
a plateau and a drop or it's still just
going to keep going up
so you'd say there's no there's no cause
for great optimism but but no need for
increased pessimism at the moment
um
i think yeah i i think it depends
whether you're an optimist or a
pessimist but um clearly the government
is is using the very much the optimistic
scenario
uh
they're using the the data from
confirmed cases rather than the
their own
ons survey which hasn't come out uh yet
which will be much more similar to the
zoe survey which reflects the real
numbers of cases because
many of the
confirmed government cases are being
missed at the moment for two main
reasons
one is that
only people who have the classic
symptoms are generally being tested
those with
flu-like symptoms that we've been
reporting on the zoe app for
over six months now
which make up about 40 45 of all cases
who never get classic symptoms
are not allowed a test unless they're on
the zoe app
and
the other reason is probably that many
people now
are doing lateral flow tests themselves
and not bothering to report that
to the government because that's in a
way independent of the government and
that that probably reflects that this
difference between the results
and uh
and it it probably even both of them are
under estimates probably because we're
not picking up on the zoe app we're not
doing asymptomatic testing routinely as
well so the numbers are really high
they're higher than any other western
country
and at the moment
it would be nice if they are going down
but i don't think there's any uh proof
that that is the case
uh as i understand you're a strong
believer that uh
immunity from the vaccines is waning uh
quite fast but possibly faster than
expected
uh
and the booster rollout is clearly not
going uh as well as the people who want
it to go are hoping
uh is this a crisis for the government
well let's put in perspective
vaccines really work so and boosters
really work and people have had the
vaccines and the booster are 95
protected
so uh that's obviously good news we got
off to a great start with our vaccines
in the uk
but um it's really petered out so we
haven't really improved our overall
vaccination status of the whole nation
above about 67
really for a couple of months whereas
other countries have have swiftly
overtaken us
and the booster program really is
struggling to keep up with the number of
people that are requesting it that are
eligible and so we're falling behind
every week so the plan is good um
there's no nothing wrong with that it's
just the delivery is too slow and too
complacent and we're about the only
country that's depending only on
vaccines and boosters and ignoring all
the other measures we could be doing to
get that that huge number of 100 you
know nearly 100 000 cases down
should we be looking to israel which
seems to have boosted its way out of a
uh a big wave
we have been looking at israel
really um
for the last uh
year because they were always ahead of
us in the vaccine race but there are
some similarities because they noticed
quite quickly that
vaccines were waning that because they
actually chose a
fisa regime that was worse than us that
didn't give as much
longevity their vaccines started to wear
off hospitalizations went up and
infections went up very badly and
only by adding in the boosters very fast
did they manage to get some control back
but they're not in a great place they've
still got high hospitalization rates and
they don't mirroring the uk a fair bit
in that
they haven't managed to get total
vaccination rates uh above uh 70 percent
of the whole population a bit like the
uk
and so they are going to keep struggling
with re-infections and
and outbreaks uh just as i think we will
is is there a mobilization problem in
that the more people sort of seem to
think that vaccines aren't as effective
as they were thought to be the less
likely they are to get boosters and if
we go on with this and we have sort of
endless boosters going on endlessly
it's going to be very hard to motivate
people or to get people to go and have
them
well i think there's been a general
failure of public uh health campaigning
really i think people are confused by
these messages
and
uh
there's been a real silence as far as i
can see in the last few months
across all media platforms of what the
health messages are
people say get your booster but at the
same time
you know not explaining exactly why that
is
explaining that yes we have high rates
but everyone with a vaccine is protected
against death and hospitalization
much more than they they would be if
they didn't have uh that jab so i think
there's a failure of communication but
there's actually no doubt that
if you've you've been infected and
you've been double vaccinated or
you've been a double vaccine and have a
booster you can have about 95 protection
against this virus which is about as
good as you can get and that really is
what people should be seeing and i think
people
as as cases are high we've got 1 in 58
people have covered people are not
stupid they're going to start
realizing how important it is and i
think we'll also start seeing some
changes in in social behavior
without waiting for the government to do
something this is what's happened in
every other um
of these
waves we've seen even before the
lockdown cases always start to come down
as people actually uh started to
opt for their own survival
and did did the right sort of thing
thank you very much tim
next up terrorism how do we talk about
terrorism in his column last week rod
little said that there is a certain
madness in the way the media discusses
terrorist acts after they have happened
depending on what the killer is or who
the killer is
peter hitchins on the spectator online
this week took great exception to rod's
column he wants us to focus on mental
illness and particularly on drug-induced
psychosis
peter what was it about what rod said
that you took such great exception to
well i think the thing that i didn't
like was these
particularly was that he said that
nobody had said at the time of the
murder of joe cox
that mayor the killer was
was actually crazy
and i had actually gone to some lengths
to point out that this was very much the
case and it got in quite a bit of
trouble from left-wing persons for
saying so
and i think that it was an important
an important point of disagreement
because so much
of the discussion about these events
is prejudiced by the desire of various
people in america
gun control liberals in this country
conservatives who see islam as a major
problem
and among the guardian reading left in
this country people who believe that
there's a huge right-wing extremist
problem in this country they all want to
believe that these events are
fundamentally political and or religious
my view of looking at very many of them
is that the
the real fundamental problem the thing
which has changed in our society most of
all in the past 50 years is the huge
number of people who are taking various
kinds of legal or illegal mind-altering
drugs and the terrible effect which this
has on them and i think that's the thing
which these events have in common and
what i really want to see is an inquiry
into every act of violence especially
lethal violence into the the drug taking
backgrounds
of the culprits because i think it would
it would uncover something quite
startling to those who think this is
fundamentally political
and i thought that the the dismissal of
the of the idea that uh
the mayor was actually really just off
his head uh was wrong
rod do you think uh in your eagerness
perhaps to uh pin the blame on islamism
you're overlooking the fact that all
these people are just mad and possibly
mad because of drugs
i don't know that's exactly what i said
i don't think the problem is islamism um
uh primarily um what i was trying to do
was change out the nuances between what
constitutes madness and what constitutes
badness if you like and incidentally
when i use the word nobody says uh as
peter quoted me of saying i i mean in a
slightly different sense to how most
people mean i mean nobody except for
peter me and melanie phillips um
so it's a
it's
nobody isn't quite the finite term it is
when ordinary people use it but i i take
peter's point uh
and and i was nudging towards
that suggestion which that
uh that uh
every single block of society has agency
when a tragedy occurs and tries to
insist that it is the consequence of
people they don't like doing it and the
thing which i found most fascinating was
unders bretvik in
norway
where initially of course the
uh psychiatrist found him a mad as a
hatter which is a
a derogation i would probably go along
with having looked at the case in full
though not having examined him
[Music]
but then this was overturned
simply or primarily
because the left wished to insist
that the the racist politics espoused by
anders brevit inevitably led to that
kind of carnage
uh and that therefore
uh it wasn't the case that he was insane
whereas clearly as one of the
psychiatrists put it i would
suggest that he was insane simply by
dint of the fact that
as his psychiatrist put it
his politics came along to provide a
space for his psychotic behavior rather
than the other way around
is the problem partly uh rod that i mean
our definition of mental illness now is
so broad it ranges from everything from
schizophrenic psychosis to just feeling
a bit down
that actually nobody can talk sensibly
about madness and and what drives mad
people to kill people
but that's certainly true that's
certainly true and we've also
gone along a bit of the path that norway
has gone along with which is to kind of
exonerate mental illness to the degree
that it is something which affects
someone and that therefore the person
cannot possibly be responsible uh now we
have a slight backlash in this country
with some very eminent people i think
uh i think it's paul morales at leeds
university uh who are positing a
post-liberal uh uh uh uh
study of insanity and suggesting that
for example
whilst mental health
charities will tell you that there is
nothing to be feared from schizophrenia
uh
paul morale and others suggest oh yes
there is and the public is absolutely
right to stay the hell away from
so there is that
and yes of course we talk far too much
about mental health none of this
incidentally
because it's something i didn't touch on
at all which is probably why peter
reacted none of this should
uh uh uh prejudice one way or the other
uh peter's excellent thesis that it's
drugs which are primarily to blame it
could well be in many cases so not i
think in anders brevit's case well this
is the problem you see you you don't
even know that diana's brevit was a user
of steroids uh
it's so i knew he used steroids but but
but but well this is it's if you're if
you're suggesting that every single
uh pharmaceutical uh pertinence uh is it
could be a contributory factor in in uh
acts of extreme violence
what i'm pointing out is that the there
has been absolutely zero interest
anywhere in the fact that brevity used
steroids
but if you look at a number of these
crimes omar martin the orlando the
orlando killer uh or you you look at the
london bridge killers uh or you look at
brenton tarrant the man who responsible
for the mosque massacre in christchurch
in new zealand they're all steroid users
so it's not the argue all you often get
from people who say oh well are you
saying everybody who smokes a joint is a
killer or everybody who takes
antidepressants is a killer or everybody
who takes steroids as a killer no i'm
not saying that
what i am saying is that if you come
across people
who have crossed this extraordinarily uh
well-patrolled boundary uh that that
keeps most of us uh from attacking our
fellow creatures with guns knives or
bombs and have actually done it that one
thing they tend to have in common
is that they have taken powerful
mind-altering drugs we don't know how
much we don't know how how long they've
done it for the reason we don't know any
of this is because nobody cares quite
often i look at crimes which are totally
irrational and i i go to the police
forces involved officers and i say could
you tell me did you investigate
the culprit's drug use
and after i've taken them in many cases
the information commissioner it emerges
they haven't even asked they're not
interested there is a fundamental lack
of interest in our criminal justice
system in this very very important point
they don't look they're not interested
they don't ask they don't care i should
think uh probably 99 percent of people
who have heard of anders breivik have no
idea uh that he took steroids and in
fact his revolting testament in which he
makes this plane uh is now almost
unobtainable uh so you can't even re to
see but that's where it is but it's in
so many cases uh whether
whether in the
terrifying number of school and college
shootings in the united states uh or in
the the the people who drive vehicles
into crowds uh on both sides of the
atlantic you will find over and over
again if you look and if there's been
any attempt to find out you will find
that the use of some sort of powerful
psychotropic is present so i can draw no
conclusions from this because the
evidence is is still too thin but i
think it's incredibly irresponsible of
our societies to put these to one side
say oh it's because there's no gun
control oh it's because of islamism or
oh it's because he was simply mad and
there's no explanation for it rather
than actually setting up what we need
which is a proper inquiry into the role
of these drugs this is new these things
are not have not gone on throughout
human history they've begun to take
place really in only since the 1960s and
they're becoming increasingly common and
if we don't find a proper explanation
for them we will not stop them and we
will live with more and more of them and
that's what i get sick of is the
immediate placing of these things into
into political categories which suit the
politics of the person who make it
rather than into
an intelligent inquiry into what's
really going on but the drugs aside
that's exactly what i was arguing about
well you can't put the drugs aside can
you in that argument the drugs are
absolutely central to that because they
are the big they're the big change
just separated i mean what i was
objecting to was that uh immediate
categorization by both right left and
right to center indeed for that matter
uh uh it's it's it's a it's a function
of our times it's a function of the
internet but closer
remind me what were you saying about the
bow and arrow uh the bow and arrow event
in norway
what was i saying about yeah what was
your view of that what were you thinking
that what were you what were you what
were you turning towards well again they
did exactly the opposite with the bow
and arrow what interested me about that
was the fact that the authorities did
the exact reverse of what they did in
the case of anders brevik which was at
first say this is a terrorist attack and
ascribed the blame to uh
to the guy's islamic beliefs his
limitless beliefs
and then
uh
within the space of only about seven
days uh changed completely and said no
it's nothing to do with islamism it's to
do with his mental health uh he's been
on antidepressants he's he's had uh
various psychotic episodes etc etc etc
and they ditched islam all together from
it uh so i mean what do i think i don't
know because i haven't interviewed
anybody who's uh
[Music]
i'm sure he's right which is that this
is something which is never investigated
and i think the reason for that is the
year which uh peter cited earlier in
1960
and i think since 1960 our view of drugs
has changed
uh which is why we have many many more
addicts
uh many many more heroin addicts as well
as addicts of various other if you wish
to call them addicts i know there's a
there's a scientific difference between
addiction and uh and uh habitual use um
because society as a whole has decided
that drugs perhaps aren't quite as bad
as things as we thought them to be 50 to
60 years ago and that colors the way in
which
we treat people who use drugs
and i would suggest that the current
leniency in the courts towards drugs is
also
a symptom of that so so to that degree i
agree with peter
well in that case surely we need to
revise our relaxation of our views on
drugs if if if the damage that
that they're doing uh could be as great
as this it's time we stopped we stopped
taking the 1960s attitude peter you've
you've been bravely banging the
the drum about cannabis induced
psychosis for a long time now and you're
one of the very few people
uh with a sort of public profile that
does it
uh and yet uh the society is going
against you you know we are moving more
and more towards uh cannabis
legalization do you think you've lost
the fight oh certainly i've lost it uh i
i've spent most of my life winning
debates and losing the vote it's
extraordinarily difficult to persuade
people
uh particularly to vote against
something which they think gives them
pleasure
and
that that's just the case but the
problem with this will be that if we
ever do get to the point of legalized
marijuana advertised everywhere and
available in in high street shops and
freely on the internet and it turns out
that i'm right about the the correlation
between marijuana use and mental illness
then it will be almost impossible to
undo the damage
so i'd say now
just imagine me cackling from whatever
post-death location i find myself into
uh i told you so uh when you've made
this mistake i don't know what else i
could do
honestly uh than what i have done to
point out this danger and also to point
out how irreversible the legalization of
drugs is i have to keep saying don't do
this stupid thing i have to keep saying
yeah sure sure
and i agree with you but
well i haven't seen i haven't seen your
piece demanding that the the um the laws
against marijuana possession
should
be i have written about that and i've
written uh i've written about our
attitudes towards drugs in general not
from the point of view of inducing
psychosis in individuals which lead to
the sort of killings you're talking of
but in the general form that
it is another factor
of
what has come out of the mid 60s partly
in the mid 60s probably probably also
the 80s and uh
the chicago school of economics partly
the frankfurt school of sociology in the
60s that that we uh that is it's all
about self-actualization
and
in short we should be allowed to do
whatever the hell we like and tied in
with that
drugs is obviously a huge problem
debt is a huge problem uh we had very
little debt you know back in the in the
early 1960s uh there was very little
personal debt
uh but also marriage uh divorce children
the way we bring up children everything
has been geared to making us uh be able
to fulfill ourselves in order to fill
our boots with whatever the hell we want
and i think drugs is absolutely a part
of that and i think you're you're right
you're banging on the right track peter
i'm sure
next up cop
for most of this year the government has
been hyping up the big climate change
summit in glasgow as a major event for
britain and the world however as this
weekend approaches there are talks of
crisis
uh some important figures including most
importantly perhaps president xi
of china the world's biggest polluter
will not be there
so is the conference going to be a giant
waste of time
fraser nelson in his cover piece this
week says that the problem with these
cop summits in general is that they
present the idea of the world agreeing
on something when in fact the world is
very much at odds
fraser joins me now with peter betts who
was the lead climate negotiator for the
united kingdom and the european union
fraser in your cover article you suggest
that cop may well turn out to be a flop
and that all the talk is largely hot air
well we've had them several in fact 26
of these cop summits and they have not
tended to be the real turning points in
the climate debate we've had a few kyoto
97 was big the paris agreement was quite
big as well but most of the cops end up
without really much anybody being much
further forward they also tend to be
events where you come up with verbal
formulae which on inspection don't
really tend to mean anything now boris
johnson's original conceit was to make
this one of the
kyoto paris leagues he wanted glasgow to
follow in that um in that line of big
cop summits by getting people to agree
to 1.5 mm degrees warming and by 2050
rather than somewhere between 1.5 and 2
in other words to go a little bit
further than paris so the paris people
would basically come with far bigger
harder firmer declarations but it
doesn't look like that's going to happen
now for the start china hasn't isn't xi
jinping isn't turning up he hasn't been
anywhere since sam covert broke out
vladimir putin who's quite the energy
broker in now europe he's got a new
pipeline willing to um give gas to
germany in the next few weeks he isn't
turning up either and without major
concessions from china you're not really
going to get a clear 1.5 degree promise
so it's not clear what if anything cop
is going to achieve i mean there'll be
plenty of discussions there'll be plenty
of joint communiques where people agree
to do this and that by 2030 or 2050. um
britain and india are going to agree
some solar initiatives for example so
there'll be plenty going on but when
history looks back at the glasgow summit
it's far from clear now but there will
be anything really significant to say
peter you've been
lead climate negotiator for the united
kingdom and for the european union uh
i'm assuming you disagree with fraser's
analysis
yeah i i do i do disagree with it
freddie um so you know this this cop is
a very different cop to the one we had
in paris six years ago so the goal of
paris is to get countries to ramp up
their emission reduction plans in
particular for the year 2030.
um how are we doing on that
well we've got commitments at the very
top end of what we thought from a bunch
of big developed countries uh except
australia but also from countries like
south africa colombia argentina and lots
of the smaller countries
as as frieza said we're still waiting
for china india
and saudi arabia the fact that they're
that some of their leaders are not there
some of them will be
doesn't mean that the pressure should be
off those countries to deliver ambitious
reduction pledges for 2030 so we need to
see what they deliver
if you actually look at what those those
pledges would deliver if you know if
they're implemented uh they're they're
clearly not nearly enough uh to close
the gap so 1.5 degrees but they're not
nothing
um you know the the united nations
environment program produces an annual
report which came out earlier this week
that that had said that broadly the
pledges made at the time of paris
might put the world on track for
something like three degrees
they're now saying that the new pledges
might put the world on track for
something more like 2.6 or 2.7 degrees
that's that's a big improvement not
enough but it's a big improvement
they also say
and you might think this is more
tentative but they also say that if
those mid-century net zero pledges that
fraser referred to were delivered
that might be mean the world is on a
trajectory of something like 2.2 degrees
so i i sort of slightly worry that
fraser as much as i'm a big fan of of
the magazine and a fraser is sort of
slightly fallen to the greta tinberg
trap of saying that you know because we
haven't achieved everything we've
achieved nothing
fraser how do you respond to the greta
thunder you are greta thundberg
allegation not a woman i'm very often
compared to and but the thing but my
point here is not that progress is being
made i'm actually a big optimist when it
comes to the sheer speed of of green
technology of renewable energy it's
coming down at an incredible rate if you
look at the the cost of wind power now
way lower than we thought it would be 10
years ago there's a fascinating paper
and from oxford i mentioned in my cover
piece that suggests that we're all
fundamentally underestimating just how
fast the new technology is going to be
and in fact we might hit net zero in 25
years and save millions and billions of
pounds in the process because the new
technology will simply be so much more
cheaper and more efficient than the old
fossil fuel now i regard that as as
plausible it's not not saying likely but
it's plausible um but i think that the
real progress doesn't tend to come at
these summits you see this the summits
give you this kind of fake theater that
force putting pressure on companies
forcing them to countries forcing them
to do this forcing them to do that that
really isn't the way it works i mean
countries move at their own pace because
ultimately
democratic leaders are not really in a
position to go to glasgow and say okay
you've persuaded me i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that even joe biden if
you look at his he says he's going to be
there with belzon he's promising that
he's going to cut america's emissions by
50 from 2005 levels that's twice the um
the speed set by barack obama but even
biden can't get that through congress
right now because as president he
struggles to get legislation passed as
do quite a lot of leaders you've got the
um australia for example it's given the
superficial 2050 commitment but no plan
at all about how you're going to get
there and it's prime minister scott
morrison jokes that he'll do it's the
australian way whatever that might be
and china hasn't said nothing
china has given us quite a clear idea it
surprised everybody last month when out
of the blue and nothing to do with cop
it said here's what we're going to do
we're going to keep our coal fires
burning i mean coal easily the dirtiest
fuel uh powers most of chinese fuel
we're going to keep this going for until
for the rest of the decade and then
we're going to increase our carbon
footprint and then we're going to hit
net zero in 2060 10 years after boris
johnson's deadline and russia saying the
same saudi arabia is saying the same so
we are seeing progress all the time but
it's just simply not bookended by these
cop summits the cop summits are little
acts of theater where they might agree
to do things but paris was effectively
toothless paris was a whole set of
agreements but it wasn't they weren't
binding on anybody and that so right now
i think we need to separate what is
happening i think i mean
we're seeing good news in the
environment pretty much every day
britain's carbon emissions for example
are now down to victorian levels we're
making incredible progress and faster
progress than any other developed
country in the last 10 years but we're
not doing that because somebody forced
us to at the climate summit we're doing
this because consumers capitalism
innovation those are the engines that
are making this
planet a cleaner and greener one
peter i'll let you come back on that
thanks thanks freddie
so maybe maybe three points uh firstly
you know like fraser i'm you know
relative optimist about the transition i
think it is going to happen i think it's
accelerating and it's driven a lot by
business and technological development
fully agree
but that development hasn't come about
by accident
it's come about in part because it's
been driven by subsidy and regulation
so if you look at you know what's
happening in india you know in india as
in many parts of the world
um
fossil renewable energy now cheaper than
fossil fuels uh in most circumstances
but
the reason that's taking off is because
it's cheaper and the reason it's cheaper
is because you know europe and elsewhere
invested really heavily in renewable
energy to scale it up to get the cost
down and they did that because they set
they set regulations and they they
entered into a commitment in a
multilateral context you know where they
felt some confidence misplaced as it
turned out i would acknowledge that
other countries and competitor countries
would also act
and you know i talk to a lot of senior
business and i think i fully agree with
phrase that they get this and they're
thinking about how they deliver but most
of the businesses i do are very clear
that they see a strong continuing role
for government to set the frameworks
standards funding innovation funny
infrastructure
you know if if we're going to do this
solve this problem
you know by 2030
so
nearly again for 90 of emissions are
going to come from the emerging
economies a lot of those emerging
economies are state-run economies
you know you you need government action
uh to to drive them
second point i would make is you know
again i agree with fraser you don't
bully countries uh
at a cop or a summit into acting you
have to find arguments that resonate
with them
you know i think there is an active
debate in china people who understand
china better than i do told me this you
know there are reasons for china to you
know as it were do the right thing you
know they
that they they are very vulnerable to
climate change
secondly they really want to move up the
value chain their entire economic
strategy is about capturing new markets
new industries and things like electric
vehicles they can steal a march on
germany they never catch up with germany
and internal combustion engines they can
on this these new technologies
and thirdly i think they do care a bit
about their reputation particularly in
developing world you know where you know
they've you know they've they've
had a few reputational issues let's put
it like that and you know they care what
developing countries think because they
want their votes in the u.n and they
want their resources so and then there
are there are other elements in china
pushing back against acting state-owned
enterprises people worried about energy
security and that is playing out
and i fully agree with fraser that we
need a much more ambitious uh
trajectory for china in 20 for the next
10 15 years than we've got at the moment
but i think their 2060 goal
is highly significant and the fact that
it's set by xi
means that you know from what i'm told
it's already starting to impact on the
system not fast enough
not enough but it isn't impacting on
major economic decision-making in china
or it's starting to
president lotte i'd just like to ask you
about the politics of this it seems to
me that boris johnson might be
brilliantly
uh undermining expectations about this
uh summit and that in the end a bit like
the olympics which has some similarities
to cop uh it'll end up being sort of all
right on the night and everyone will
think it's not quite the disaster that
seems to be in the newspapers at the
moment do you think that might happen
it's tempting to think that but boris
will come up trumps in the end because
that tends to be his history as a
politician he looks as if he's flailing
around he's not going to make it but at
the last minute he seizes victory from
the jaws of defeat
this time around it really is difficult
i mean let's face it china is the
problem here if china's growth had
tracked africa's growth from 1990 there
would be nowhere near as much of a
climate problem the concentration of co2
is to a large extent because chinese are
simply not poor in the way they once
were they're now living a lot more like
us and they intend to do so india
there's 115 million people below the
poverty line in extreme poverty india
wants fewer of those people so they're
going to keep going and there's nothing
you can really do at a climate summit to
to change those parameters um now what
we can probably expect of this is a form
of words in these summits they're
basically there is drama there is hail
to be a great agreement and quite often
has written up as a great breakthrough
but when you boil it down and look at
the commitments what do they actually
mean has anything really moved on and
it's the same not just for the cop 26
summits but ball summits the g8 summit
and i remember the g8 summit at glen
eagles gordon brown came up with this
this great fake figure of a trillion
pounds they were going to give to the um
developing world or something like that
it turns out the figure was completely
fake put together in some way or another
that's what these summits do and this is
which is why i don't think that it's
right to see the history of
environmentalism as being bookended by
these cop summits and oxford's dj helm
was at the um spectators climate summit
on monday he made the very good point
that since coyote you've had a golden
age of fossil fuels not environmentalism
you've had absolute surge look at obama
he increased significantly america's
fossil fuel production because they
discovered fracking technology and
thought this clean and cheap gas would
be um too good an opportunity to waste
so those are the kind of things that
really um tilt the environmental
direction it wouldn't surprise me at all
if boris johnson does come up with a
triumphant form of words and he might
say as they're already saying look look
at look right when we started this
system
the countries who signed up to net 50
agreements spoke for 30 of the world's
economy now it's 80 percent that is the
right the main kind of boost if you like
so
if there's nothing better to say than
that then we won't have made much
progress but also remember ready cop 26
is a two-week summit and britain's
chairmanship is one long year so don't
think we're going to be done with this
in just a few
days we better wrap it up there but uh
peter and fraser thank you very much
great thanks very much
lastly we move on to facebook this week
francis haugen a former facebook
employee has been talking to mps in
london
about online harm but is something more
nefarious afoot is this a grave threat
to free speech
i'm joined now by ben smith the new york
times media columnist
and glenn greenwald the journalist who's
based in brazil
ben i'll start with you in your column
or last column you described francis
haugen as a power player
as far as i can see it she's not exactly
a whistleblower in the normal sense of
the word even though everybody's calling
her a whistleblower
did i yikes um
you know i guess i think she is actually
a fairly traditional whistleblower she's
somebody who works inside a big
institution who didn't like what she saw
and went to um to the government in the
media
also taking with her
a huge trove of documents um
you know i do think there is a
for a lot of people in that position
there's basically a choice that i know
glenn has you know it's a difficult
choice actually of do you
you know
do you stay secret in which case the
only people who know you who you are are
your enemies which is to say the people
you used to work for
or do you
become public either because you like
the idea of being a public figure and an
advocate or because it provides a kind
of protection and makes it harder for
your
former employer to go after you but also
makes you a target and potentially a lot
and and turns
you into sort of a line of attack and a
distraction potentially from the
documents than from what you what you
leaked and you know i do think there's
this sort of question of and i think the
journal didn't really write much about
how again her point of view wasn't
particularly reflected in their articles
like they took that you know they looked
at the documents they took their own
line on them um and didn't kind of
filter them through her lens which i
think is basically appropriate but she
has a kind of a
eccentric lens is the wrong word but
like not a conventional set of views
she's against encryption she's for
certain kinds she has a lot of thoughts
about algorithms she doesn't have a
a a sort of set of views that fits
neatly into the political landscape
you're being very fair there but she was
at some point her her calls her
whistleblowing was taken over by
a communication firm run by bill burton
who's a former
deputy white house press secretary under
obama um
there's a there is a politicized agenda
behind
um her press campaign and it's become
coordinated with lots of different other
magazines now hasn't it
magazines i don't think there's a large
magazine conspiracy here no i mean what
i'm saying at some point in september
which is to say
so she she went to a firm called
whistleblower aid which is a non-profit
law firm that helped her through and
that she worked with i think through
much of the year so she and after by
which point she'd given the wall street
journal all these documents in the
journal most i think to me like the most
there's been a lot of interesting
writing about these documents but the
journals is they had a lot of time with
them and it's really the definitive
stuff um
and
and so and then come
i guess mid-september so after all
that's done and and just as she was
about to go on 60 minutes she hired a
fancy pr firm but and and there is now a
kind of swirl of conspiracy around her
fancy pr firm but i don't know if i was
a whistleblower i was about to go in 16
minutes i'd probably hire a fancy pr for
him to help me prepare like i don't
think there was
i don't know and and
yeah i i mean i having dug into it a bit
i i there was less of that than i
expected honestly what i meant by the
other media titles is that she just got
other media titles got involved with it
well she offered i mean there was a huge
i mean she has this huge trove of
documents you've given them exclusively
to the journal everybody else wanted
them
you know she had
a point of view on who she wanted to
have them and how you know and i think
there is again like always a question of
do you just dump them all on the
internet for interpretation
misinterpretation you know this they're
full of unredacted names of random
individuals who work for facebook do you
give them to a reporter who will
interpret them i think she's trying to
find some kind of middle ground where
she gives them to a lot of reporters who
will interpret them so which i don't
think it's been like perfectly executed
but i don't think it's that interesting
glenn you know a fair bit about
whistleblowing
uh
what do you think about this story and
what do you think about whistleblower
aid which is a group that is funded by
your old boss
yeah i think the question of whether
she's a whistleblower is a little bit of
a semantic distraction i largely agree
with ben that she did take documents
without authorization from a powerful
corporation and
brought them to the media for public
reporting because she believed the
public had the right to know in that
sense i
think she falls at least into a very
broadly defined range of what
whistleblowing is generally
whistleblowing by its definition means
you're blowing the whistle on wrongdoing
or corruption
and that's where i think the
question is interesting i'm not i don't
think that the document she revealed
told us very much about facebook we
didn't already know
there has been reporting on almost all
of this as opposed to say what edward
snowden revealed which
basically nobody knew or chelsea manning
which basically nobody knew most of what
she these documents are revealing are
things that have been alleged about
facebook or even demonstrated about
facebook
for a long time i think what's more
interesting is how she's being
weaponized and
the
central storyline of
her emergence is really not these
documents but her
wide range of opinions some of which ben
alluded to
she's against encryption she doesn't
think facebook should be
uh
smashed or broken up under anti-trust
laws she obviously does believe though
there's insufficient amounts of
censorship or content moderation
whatever you want to call it and that's
where i do think that the groups that
are working with her
come into play because
the context for all of this is that the
democratic party since 2016 blame
facebook for their loss to trump
they have blamed facebook over the last
four years for the emergence of
right-wing
uh ideologues and polemicist and for
giving them a platform they obviously
are agitating for greater censorship of
them and so the fact that she's working
for example with this whistleblower aid
group which is funded in part by pierrot
mittyard the former uh my former
publisher at the intercept um who has a
lot of strong opinions about the need
for greater content moderation and
whistleblower 8 itself is founded by
mark zaid who
kind of became the social media
celebrity
by spending four years just publishing
standard anti-trump resistance direct on
twitter
and it's a very odd kind of label for
this organization claiming they're in
defense of whistleblowers since mark
zade was one of the primary and still is
critics of both julian assange and
edward snowden believes that both
should be imprisoned for decades a
really weird whistleblower advocate he
seems much more interested in
whistleblowers when they
advanced a certain agenda so that i
think is what matters is how she's being
exploited she's in london to talk about
a bill that may impose criminal
penalties on social media companies that
allow content that governments or
whoever
believe is harmful or foul in the words
of boris johnson there's a clear agenda
going on
that
in part she agrees with but i think in
part she's being exploited to advance
and the the agenda seems to be pushed
quite happily by let's call it legacy
media you know traditional media
is this just a sort of uh resentment
among
our industry for what facebook is doing
to us
i don't think it's just that i mean
obviously
facebook is a huge competitor
to the largest corporate media outlets
but also to small newspapers small
newspapers are dying across the united
states in large part because google and
facebook have taken all the ad revenue
that once sustained them so this
competition
is very real i think though there's on
the level of national media an
ideological war going on for who i mean
the facebook is one of the most potent
instruments ever devised for controlling
the dissemination of information around
the world there are two billion users or
however many
are
is the accurate account it has
incredible influence as do as does
google's youtube
on the politics of numerous
strategically critical countries and i
think what's going on is a war over who
gets to wield that power do we leave
that power in the hands of mark
zuckerberg
and google executives to decide what can
and can't be heard on the internet
or do we allow tech reporters at the new
york times and disinformation
units of nbc news to pressure these
companies to censor more in accordance
with their ideology or do we allow the
democratic party as they're doing to
explicitly threaten these companies and
if they don't start censoring more
they'll be subjected to regulatory and
legal reprisals or even in the uk and
canada where they're being threatened
with criminal prosecution if they don't
censor more i think that's really what
the key context here is is that facebook
and google are uniquely powerful
weapons of information and there's a war
going on currently over who gets to
decide how those weapons are utilized um
so i hesitate to pick a fight an
argument with glenn greenwald because
not only will i lose but he will never
let it go and will be
will be owning me on twitter for for
years to come
um
but i i think that he oversimplified
this in various ways one is that the you
know as i totally agree that francis
howard's um
revelations were not
on an order of magnitude of edward
snowden's weren't
but but i also think that you know what
exactly is new is complicated a lot of
the things that snowden revealed were in
some ways known there had been earlier
whistleblowers you had been writing
about them glenn that's why he found you
not everything not a lot of the worst
details but sometimes
a new
massively causes something to break into
the public consciousness and the
legislative
consciousness even though bits and
pieces of it were previously known and
so i and i think that that's true here
the that
i told she couldn't there wasn't some
massive new revelation but for instance
the kind of detailed internal
conversations about what happened after
they switched to this metric called
meaningful social engagement what the
internal arguments were what the
trade-offs were how they
you know what the internal
recommendations they took and ignored
were was really new and was interesting
i thought and it wasn't it was sort of
the the technical mechanics of stuff
that you could see from the outside um
so i think that was new and then i think
i guess i don't really think the word
censorship is the right word here there
is real censorship trump was deleted
trump's account was suspended that
censorship clearly but i don't think a
choice
facebook banned the linking to the new
york post article or twitter ban yeah on
facebook yeah that's that's sure
censorship seems like a good word for
that but whether you show my whether you
actively display content say what i mean
i i'm gonna post that the vaccine
puts magnets in your body and and causes
you to get magnetized i kind of think i
should probably be allowed to post that
on my personal facebook page
the choice of whether to distribute that
to your grandmother or not
is a complicated choice and whether you
do it or not it's not
a stranger who doesn't follow me just
because lots of people argue with me i
post something and saying lots of people
argue with me facebook then chooses to
display it to my grandmother to your
grandmother who has no connection to me
i don't think it's calling for
censorship to say hey don't display that
to glenn's grandmother it is calling for
not amplifying for muting or downplaying
certain kinds of information it's an
argument about distribution but i don't
think censorship's the right word for
that like facebook's making an active
decision to display insane and sane and
wonderful things and bad things and the
dress which i published at buzzfeed was
wonderful to lots and lots of people who
didn't actually sign up and ask for that
thing right so
i don't think it's censorship to not ben
it's quite odd is it not that it is
always facebook at these sort of
governmental inquiries it's always
facebook that is in the the sites of
governments
i think if the spectator was as powerful
as facebook lots of people would care
about the stuff but
yeah except except i mean probably the
most powerful company
um
is is not even facebook but google and
there seems to be a lot less attention
on on them
um i mean they're more powerful i think
in enormous ways including what you end
up finding on the internet obviously
they control youtube which is a gigantic
platform there was just a really
interesting article today in the new
york times on scientists who are mapping
out the brains of fruit flies in order
to do that they need to rely on google's
artificial intelligence scientists which
google basically has a virtual monopoly
on
um and very few people know even what it
is that they're doing i think google's
probably the most powerful company ever
in existence so i think it is
interesting that there is so much
attention on facebook and i think part
of that is sometimes just kind of
a little bit of a coincidence that there
was this person from facebook maybe if
there was from google we'd be talking
about google instead
but i think facebook has become more of
a lightning rod because
and this often gets lost is
most of these tech executives these
founders of companies like jack dorsey
and and certainly mark zuckerberg when
they began their vision was never that
they would be involved in censorship
fights or content moderation or whatever
you want to call it obviously why would
they want that they wanted as many
people on their platforms as possible
they didn't want to be in the process in
the habit of kicking people off
but beyond that they had they came from
this kind of libertarian ideology i mean
if you read kind of the triumphalist
euphoric
essays about the power of the internet
in the mid 90s and into the arts it was
very much this idea that it would
empower human beings to communicate
without the interference of centralized
corporate and state control that was the
ideology that they grew out of and a lot
of the censorship that these companies
now practice
are the byproduct of the fact that
they're receiving tons of external
pressure from corporate media outlets
from democratic party from
there's such naivete to say that what's
happening on facebook is communication
without corporate or state control when
in fact you have a highly centralized
corporation making decisions about what
gets distributed no it's no longer
a realization that i know there's always
that control i know but no but
but when they began there was none and
when twitter became they were there was
none
and when google actually started their
idea was we'll never tinker with the
algorithms and the reason this happened
if you go and talk to people like jack
dorsey or mark zuckerberg is they'll say
we this obligation was foisted upon us
by a society that told us that if we
don't undertake this responsibility to
police the internet responsibly
that the results of free speech and the
blood that it sheds will be on our
hands and they're clearly
there clearly is
a very aggressive and coordinated
campaign to pressure these companies to
censor more democratic members of
congress have summoned these tech
executives four times in the last 12
months to be interrogated before them
and each time they say to them
explicitly
our problem with you is not that you're
censoring
too much it's that you're not censoring
enough and if you don't start getting
more hate speech and disinformation as
we understand it off of your platforms
you're going to pay a price legally and
in terms of regulation that is the
conflict explicitly being undertaken
i mean i think i agree with you on the
motivations around kind of the
post-trump freak out and seeing facebook
as the sole reason or russia and they're
kind of but i also think that there was
a shift from like no one is there is no
call to censor my texts with you even if
we are fomenting if even if i'm texting
you disinformation because there's an
understanding that like that that's a
passive medium that at t is providing us
to text
facebook when it was displaying things
in a reverse chronological feed from
your friends was a different company
than when facebook was choosing which
content to distribute and
spread widely and which not once they
are making those choices it seems
totally reasonable for lots of different
people to have opinions on the choices
that they're making it's not passive
it's not neutral there's no there's no
neutral space where they're just saying
well we're just throwing it all out
there and whatever wins wins it's all
active choices and so i don't see why
lots of people shouldn't have opinions
on those choices that they're making
about what to publish and what to
distribute right so let me just i think
this is the key i totally agree that
this distinction that ben is drawing
between
passive permission to users to publish
whatever they want and active decisions
to algorithmically promote or suppress
things is a critical distinction once
they get into the role of
algorithmically promoting or suppressing
they're really kind of like
a publisher like the new york times
actually and ben is right once you start
making those choices you can be
criticized like people criticize new
york times all the time for stuff that
they choose to publish or withhold the
difference though
is if
the democratic party started dragging
you know
executive editors and senior editors of
the new york times before the congress
to say
you better stop publishing op-eds like
this or we're going to be punishing you
legally people would understand that's
really menacing
so if what facebook you are doing is
similar that we should see the same
danger there
i think it is dangerous and menacing i
think also remember the phrase was a
vast cultural wasteland television
executives were always getting dragged
in front of congress to get yelled at
about the garbage they were spreading
that's long i mean you know that's
that's that's most of the second half of
the 20th century i mean i don't think
yeah
and and people reacted that very poorly
like particularly
part of the reason there is television
news love it or hate it that is fat
tries to be factual and fair
is because they were under all this
pressure from congress and from citizens
not just to provide entertaining garbage
i mean like that was that's that's the
history of the television industry this
isn't some like radical new twist no
exactly i agree that if the democratic
party was saying my opinion about
facebook is it permits too much
right-wing opinion to be heard that it
makes ben shapiro be able to reach 5
million people and that seems bad i have
no problem with that when you start
saying if you continue to allow ben
shapiro to be heard on your platform
we're going to pass laws or enact
regulations designed to punish you in in
retaliation for allowing ideas that we
dislike to be heard
then it becomes an entirely different
type of reaction you move from critique
to state control and there's actually
you know supreme court cases that say
obviously the first amendment bars the
congress from directly censoring right
congress couldn't pass a law
that said facebook is hereby prohibited
from allowing any pro-republican party
content on their platform but there's
case law where
state officials in the past have kind of
coerced or implicitly threatened
bookstores or other book distributors to
say
if you continue to allow these books
that we think are too risque to be
available in the bookstore you're going
to have a lot of problems with their
zoning commission and state you know
supreme court has said once you start
doing that kind of coercion you really
get into a realm where it becomes more
like the kind of direct censorship the
first amendment prohibits then just to
say i i can listen to you both are you
about free speech all along but i know
ben's got to go ben i'll let you have
the last word then i think we better
wrap it up
oh wow the last word i mean i guess i
agree with a lot of what ben said what
glenn is saying i think there's a ton of
danger here when the government is
involved in in speech i just think that
and i guess in some ways it's easier to
for me to talk about the vaccines stuff
than about politics because i think
there's less space for legitimate
disagreement and i think the question
which i think is actually hard to answer
is you know how many
cops would have marched on new york city
hall yesterday denouncing vaccines
without facebook right i'm not really
sure i actually don't i think that
that's a really interesting question but
i think probably some that there
probably is some effect on something
that is just obviously making society
like just an obvious social ill that i
think it's reasonable for legislators to
think about you know how can you improve
public health by getting people
vaccinated and not have people spread
lies about vaccines that doesn't seem
crazy to me i totally agree it's a foot
on a slippery slope and all sorts of
other crazy stuff but i don't know i
don't think it's that supple
glenn and ben thank you very much indeed
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
the show don't forget to subscribe to
our youtube channel and to repeat you do
that by hitting the button at the bottom
of the screen
and then clicking the bell to get a
reminder every time so you don't miss an
episode
that's all for now thank you very much
do tune in next week
i hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
you